donc ici tu peux tout dire vraiment
xavier et voilà tu préfères la bad à
l'abricot tu nous le dit on les eaux
nous sommes des abonnements des fruits
donc voilà nous avons des atouts
donc voilà n'hésite pas non plus à
xavier c'est les femmes oui donc ces
femmes qu'est-ce que tu acceptes de
partir avec williams qui est quand même
voilà être relooké tu vas revenir dans
un instant est ce que tu veux je te
fasse un petit bisou avant pourquoi pas
est ce que tu peux être un petit bisou
et nicole avant que tu partes
j'ai compris la personne
la plupart des libyens si t'es pas là
dans une heure je lance à l'avis de
recherche où tu passes par là allez
allez y avec william merci messieurs
non mais vraiment on encore enfin petit
débrief entre nous au je trouve très
sympathique moque c'est très sympa mais
je pense qu'en fait il comme lille il
est tétanisé par l'enjeu 2 il faut que
ça fonctionne à tout prix c'est ça et
comme il veut que ça fonctionne à
toulouse il devient gauche alors les
campings c'est simplement un bonjour
amical tout d'un coup il est tout à fait
à l'aise
allez moi mais moi moi j'ai connu ça -
vous avez réalisé par l'enjeu oui oui je
suis tétanisé pas vous vous êtes
tétanisé me shoote les anisés par
l'enjeu oui madame laquelle mamba un
tournoi d'échecs
non mais franchement je suis tétanisé
par un jeune homme et c'est vrai que
quand on a pu vous dire quand on
commence à avoir des sentiments pour une
femme c'est c'est là qu'on est on n'est
pas bon non mais c'est vrai quand on
s'en fout on y va c'est vous pas le
spécialisés ben oui pour fait plus la
tendance à petit toit la personne nous
plaît puis c'est difficile
enfin c'est sûr qu'une fille si elle
nous a tjrs et moi nous attire mais
c'est vrai aussi pour les fils a cessé
dans les deux sens a eu combien de
conquête vous en tout beaucoup ont même
beaucoup bien combien d'ipad bonnici
c'est exact le gâteau à 10 a dû juste au
prix hamad
cher peu cher non combien même pas 300
de 300 cédant là c'est dans la moyenne
du chili à dos chez je sois beaucoup
croissant c'est moi que jean michel
maire il a dit qu'il avait 1200 conquête
mais moi il est beaucoup plus âgée lac
avec toute sa force et vous nichols avec
moins de conquête
faites moi comme ça alors là je c'est
vrai que j'aurais tendance à dire je les
compte pas non plus mais avec mon grand
âge cyril 57
combien de gens nuit vraiment beaucoup
si je peux compter également les petites
choses les petite séduction comme il y
en a 300
non mais
mais rencontrent les rapports bucco
dentaire dont convient aussi
non je plaisante non ne suis pas là 300
+ 900 303 vous êtes sur le oui mais en
même temps il ya une différence d'âge
voilà et va très bien eh ben c'est
normal qu'il en est - ben oui oui c'est
ce souvent le cas oui c'est sûrement la
poupée naim tiens vous à peu près avec
moi j'suis sur une fourchette de 4 5 à 4
5 oui c'est guy degrenne à l'offre et
pour certaines c'est là guy degrenne du
sexe n'en serai à huy 7 5
bah oui je ne demanderai pas notre
psychologue sexologue mais je lui
demander quand même non mais vous
n'étiez pas là pour ça qu'à ou tard mais
ça se compte sur les doigts d'une seule
main ah bah non seulement comme un oui
pas vrai et je sais pas si vous avez
remarqué chez vous à chaque fois qu'on
sort avec une meuf elle nous fait et ben
maintenant à cause de toi je dois avoir
besoin de ma deuxième main pour compter
mes mecs en short et toujours le sixième
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
non mais c est qu de rose on voit là où
on s'en fout mais voilà alors où est ce
que vous pensez que vous allez pécho
dans les prochaines années j'ai parié
cloud ou pas savage escrime peau est ce
qu'il vous faut
elle est livrée avec vous extrêmement
fermes entre la femme de code je n'ai vu
tout à l'heure dans les loges qu'ils
étaient ensemble main dans la main je
peux vous dire les deux il ya de l'amour
et en parlant d'amour justement on how
is m
wissem ou kinkela qui est là depuis le
début de l'émission qui émane est
regardé comme il est mignon mignon sans
rigoler très vite whissell très très
beau challenge
la coiffure sur le côté il à la coiffure
pujadas mais avec du gel
[Rires]
plus m lui serve vous avez 23 ans 33
dont je vais tutoyer oui c'est moche tu
fais quoi dans la vie wissem je suis
commerçant comme commerçant commercial
commerçants commercial versant d'angoua
commerçants dans quoi marchés en fruits
et légumes ont marqué les airs et ouais
mais je fais marcher pendant des années
journée des chemises en fait vous auriez
pu faire témoin de toutes les histoires
là c'est vrai mesdames vous êtes venus
supporter champ là où il sert au marché
donc vous habitez ou à lyon
non j'adore c'est souvent vécu à lyon et
vous vendez quoi sur le marché textile
chaussures textile chaussures des
chaussures en textile très bien j'aime
beaucoup alors vous venez pas nous voir
pour parler marcher vous venez le voir
pour parler amour en fait vous voulez
reconquérir votre ex c'est ça ouais ça
3 qu'est ce qui s'est passé bah il s'est
passé que elle m'a dit tu es là vous
acquittez vous étiez ça faisait comme
maintenant vous étiez avec elle ça
faisait quatre ans
4 on highway quoi depuis l'âge de 19 ans
18h24 également membre
ouais 18 ans 18 ans 19 ans ouais mais
bon quoi vous acquittez vous avez fait
une bêtise
ouais j'ai trompé non oui mais oui la
troupe et trompait wii se faire choper
non
déjà qu est ce qui s'est passé raconte
nous comment tu t'es fait choper bas au
début elle a pas vus généralement quand
tu trompes ta meuf elle est rarement sur
les unions du pays wissem je te vois oui
je vais je te vois ben voila je te vois
je te vois avec la personne en wissem
n'ont donc oui donc ça on s'en doutait
donc comment ça s'est passé ce qu avec
cuba à bettié bah oui j'ai trompé
plusieurs fois aussi là justement que se
pose la question fille est ce qu'il vaut
mieux que votre mec vous trompe
plusieurs fois que ce soit pas sérieux
ou qui vous trompe une fois et que ce
soit sérieux
nicole qui trompe pas du tout voilà
[Rires]
on sort de la fiction pas ça la réalité
la question on voulait dire ça non quoi
une fois nom plusieurs fois et plusieurs
fois à rayer pas troubler rien oui
évidemment dans sa grille parce que on
se dit que ce n'est pas une seule femme
pour nous remplacer c'est qu'il a juste
un problème fidélité voilà c'est ça vous
pourrez faire huriez que pato ne vous
trompe une fois bien sûr faut que tu vas
tu es le tout j'ai des vidéos alors on
va faire une île de la tentation qu'avez
vous vu qu avez-vous
[Rires]
je vais répondre un petit peu comme
valérie or vaut mieux pas mais au moment
voulu que ce soit ponctuelle et y rentre
à la maison après c'est vrai vous
pourrez avoir donné je pense oui et vous
côte juste pour le plaisir d'entendre de
vous entendre
oui tout simplement d'accord donc vous
non alors oui c'est 1000 va nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé il ya un
instant avec avec sa copine qui
s'appelait comment s'appelle manon et
s'appelle manon willaya voulait plus du
tout de nouvelles mais l'habit de vers
chez moi donc deux fois je vois mais
elle veut pas vous parler à veut pas du
tout là c'est fini comment vous êtes
fait choper qu'est ce qui s'est passé on
va essayer de vous aider ici autour de
la table dans un instant également
yakuza dié qui va revenir relooké et là
je peux vous dire le xavier relooké sava
pécho ici dans sur ce plateau là je me
sens très bien
il est parti avec william carnimolla
vous avez vu les deux ces deux salles
deux ambiances
on se retrouve dans un instant et on
dirait que c'est les 35 heures à tous
mr
on embrasse enrique iglesias voilà tous
ceux qui nous regardent pendant ses 35
heures voilà de la santa lucia la
pizzeria merci j'adore non mais j'adore
cette chanson a weak exercer votre style
à éliminer la 41 non j'ai vu les
assoiffés beaucoup plus jeune vrai c'est
vrai il a il arrive à mon âge
ah bah vous fait plusieurs voitures
faites vous faites plus nous voir comme
vous quand vous me verrez à la télé l'an
prochain premier constat d'accord merci
en tout cas merci d'être avec nous il
est 15 heures 22 ans ça fait déjà une
heure 22 que nous sommes dans direct
donc déjà ya milo est vraiment là
quelque chose qui va arriver ce soir
touche pas à mon poste bien sûr
formidable et derrière on aura c'est
pour nous c'est cadeau de folie la folie
la folie la folie pour le moment on
attend dans un instant xavier qui est
parti se faire relooker par william
carnimolla si vous nous rejoignez vous
aviez c'est un jeune homme qui à 30 ans
qui n'a jamais connu l'amour qui n'a
jamais connu davanture qui est
sympathique mais qui n'arrive pas à
faire le nid le premier panier le
dernier pas donc voilà donc il va se
faire relooker par williams et on nous
sommes avec également wissem wissem il a
23 ans il est célibataire à son grand
malheur puisque voilà il aurait préféré
être avec avec son ex s'appelle manon
c'est ça ça me rappelle que vous étiez
avec elle pendant quatre ans et manon
malheureusement vous a grillé elle a
remarqué que vous la trompiez c'est ça
ce sera combien de fois c'est qu'elle
commence assez fait qu'est ce que je
crains c'est beaucoup et beaucoup mais
quoi dans mes champs comment comment là
comment la remarque est bancable auto
sur le portable
non oui même photo sur le portage mais
oui mais
alors là au portable pour ce pour ceux
qui ont des choses à cacher et pas mon
cas bien entendu vous pouvez prendre mon
portable d'un doute il ya une
application vous allez dans la
calculatrice quoi oui nous dit une
calculatrice vous faites un code et vous
arrivez sur des photos je vous le dis
bah oui bac aurait dû m'appeler
ce document sera capable de le faire
vous le savez je suis assez nul donc
vraiment avoir pour elle et sur ma
calculatrice taper tous les trucs vous
verrez d'après ben ali si alors
franchement balles et six médailles mais
vous savez moi j'ai rien moi je vais
vous dire je veux dire beinheim chez
rien à cacher aux français
ainsi vous avez quelque chose à cacher
la calcule en malaisie a laissé voir la
calculatrice bâle a déjà trouvé l'appui
on sera pas nous sommes donc qu'est ce
qu'elle a trouvé des photos de moi avec
une fille non comment à l'hôtel déjà à
l'hôtel au coi nu non ça jamais j'avais
la couette quoi j'avais la couette sur
moi et est donc oui ouais à la vue et à
la vue des photos de marrakech elle voit
que j'étais chez moi à lyon mais juste à
marrakech
je sais pas c'était la débandade du coup
c'était pas mais tout portable voilà
tout vu d'un coup non vous plaire elle a
tout vu d'un coup hélas hélas où vous
avez dit ce n'est pas du tout ce que tu
crois moi je dis au début ça avantage
c'est un montage
après on a vu sur un site de rencontres
non il est chaud comme un barbecue c'est
un weber le gars non m mais pourquoi est
ce que vous êtes pourquoi est ce que
vous avez eu envie d'aller vie les
jeunes ya 23 ans j'avais trois ans déjà
l'armée pourraient cesser vie d'acteur
lui à l'ordre public alors oui c'est
donc oui
après je suis comme ça moi je suis si
c'est un impulsif impulsif mais je sais
pas je vois une fille ça y est ah oui
euh quoi sert et ben nicole est ce que
vous pourriez sortir avec un garçon si
jeune que oui c'est bien en sachant tout
ça non non ne sachant pas non non oui
mais il ya une mentalité qui moi j'aime
bien j'ai une mentalité qui me convient
pas et vous pourriez sortie avec nicole
voulu sabrer grave toutes les femmes ah
oui il benhaim normal allal ben ali mais
dans ce cas là focus d'alexis cotonou
donc vous dites oh non mais attendez non
mais non mais c'est vrai donc là vous
êtes un séducteur ans je passais twitter
je me suis je me serais je suis passé
jupiter mais mais j'aime les femmes
qu'aux non alors donc je vois pas
pourquoi vous êtes là parce que vous me
dites que vous aimez les femmes c'est
l'impression que vous n'avez pas du tout
envie de changer non mais c'est vrai et
dans le côté vous dit que vous avez
envie de croire et votre ex parce
qu'elle me manque quand même un peu oui
mais vous manquent mais oui mais est-ce
que si vous reprenez avec est ce que
vous allez être sage franchement alors
un monde à notre psychologue qu'ils
disent est ce que vous le croyez kaoutar
j'ai pas le prendre ou pas le croire
mais la question c'est peut-être qu
est-ce qui a changé qu'est ce qui est
différent aujourd'hui ben allal à un
pull à moi déjà chez elle
et nous met le mec ses stylistes
benetton non mais sans déconner ça coûte
cher
wissem qu'est ce qui a changé
vous vous êtes rendu compte que vous
l'aimiez ce sont vous ben ouais je laime
à à éliminer at il aussi les mignons et
amoureux ben oui c est donc et vous
seriez prêt à faire tous les efforts
pour ne plus à tromper ou pas ouais je
vais essayer s'il me rends mon pull déjà
fait non vous allez essayer où vous
allez y arriver je vais arriver alors
non mais est ce que vous l'avez revue
est ce que vous avez essayé de la
reconquérir ou pas du tout ouais je sais
quoi genre quoi par des sms tout
j'allais signer chez elle ah ouais je
faisais tout - jallet cheminée chez elle
je l'appelais par messages appelés jeux
l'envoi des messages et et vous allez
voir son frère
ah ouais je mets ma dit trop c'est trop
cela m'a pardonné une fois deux fois
trois fois pas d'accord à d'accord elle
ne savait pas tous âges des trucs on a
soulevé un lièvre apparemment non et est
donc et donc elle vous agri quoi vous
appartenez combien de fois pendant trois
ans m'a pas donné
ouais et là elle a dit stop terminée
elle en a parlé à ses parents à ses
copines tout ça je pense ça c'est le
plus dur face à sa copine façon il a une
copine je n'aime pas mais alors je vous
le dis quand elle parle à sa meilleure
copine et qu'elle dit que vous l'avez
trompé et tout ça pour reprendre après
c'est compliqué c'est vraiment compliqué
ce que vous avez vraiment envie de la
reconquérir à ce que claude est ce que
vous pensez qu'il va réussir à la
reconquérir os penser que cette histoire
et est définitivement morte
bon mon histoire elle est complètement
morte
il l'a alors là là est-ce que c'est
l'homme qui parle ou est ce que c'est le
bruit d'un seul moyen c'est le voit non
mais j'ai pas tiré je vais pas tirer car
franchi reuters n'y a pas tiré de cartes
mais il a même pas besoin apparemment
[Rires]
c'est loupé c'est le pitch c'est le p-dg
a parlé alors glissé m
j'ai une petite révélation à vous faire
oui parce que vous savez que moi j'aime
l'amour j'aime la vie j'aime les couples
j'aime les gens qui se retrouvent
oui mais alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait
mais je vais vous le dire on a contacté
manon elle nous a dit arrêter de me
parler de ce connard non on a contacté
man elle était là quoi je n'ai vu
l'endettement
même si c'est une erreur de régime
oui oui nous sommes toujours sur ses
visites et oui on va faire 35 heures oui
enfin avoir des maires des techniques
et alors ça on pourra pas nous les
prendre c'est pas sur tf1
voilà qui va arriver là a abîmé un truc
là nous c'est comme ça c'est aussi c'est
la marque de fabrique de la chaîne a
donc vous êtes en train de me dire que
je voulais faire le malin en vous disant
manon et là vous avez vu ma non ouais je
vais vous êtes sûrs certains
ce n'est pas un mirage c'est que parfois
il ya des givrés venu vous avez reconnu
bas c'est normal ça pousse et ya quatre
ans avec elle
normalement on reconnaît la personne
enfin les contours voilà qu'en allemand
eh bien elle est allée elle est
actuellement présente dans nos studios
elle est devant la porte du studio elle
vous à regarder et elle veut rester de
dos donc de dos même de dos vous l'avez
vous l'avez reconnu grâce je reconnus et
alain d'eau assez je connais son nom
bientôt vous allez connaître sa maman sa
gueule
donc marion aynaud d'eau et même de dos
elle est magnifique c'est rare les
jambes au dodo lamelles de public il a
vu manon et les tabous modèle de dos
weber également
est-ce qu'on peut juste faire repasser
le garde qui viendra c'est là parce que
j'ai quand même il ya un gars qui passe
mais très beau gosse c'est lui là et le
gardien vous savez ces dégâts
normalement qu'on croise qu'à la salle
de muscu
j'adore il est beau il est beau gaza il
sait qu'on parle de lui là va nous péter
la gueule s'appelle youssef voilà merci
ben alors manon est là allez on reprend
notre sérieux parce que la manon il a
man on man on l a souhaité rester de
haut elle va nous parler
vous voyez où ils s'aiment mano oui ça
vous fait plaisir de le voir quand même
oui mais pas puisque cela et pourquoi
vous n'avez pas aimé c'est ce qu'il a
dit non mais je crois qu'il a un
déconneur et rigoler un peu ma non je
connais bien je le connais bien
mais bah je sais pas moi je crie je
connais moins est bon qu'est-ce qui fait
la wiz m
est-ce que manon est ce que vous êtes
prises depuis la rupture avec wissem ben
oui depuis la rupture au début oui mais
j'ai su
j'ai surmonté par sa web web j'ai été
bien entouré et puis voilà ah ouais
alors si vous avez réussi pour vous
[ __ ] sur la gueule moi je non moi j'ai
encore trente trois heures à faire si
c'est pour moi rejoint les gens se
[ __ ] sur la gueule
[Applaudissements]
oui oui c'est je savais un peu son
masque de rigoler john peut-être faire
une jolie déclaration riches m
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire à
manon et la vraie déclaration du caire
auc est pas si tu en as envie auquel
ouais j'en ai envie vas-y tu vas
toujours partout j'ai pas pardonné
encore tu vas rien hein quand tu parles
tu ça rigole ça a toujours été ça le
premier acte on n'arrive pas être
sérieux ça moi je déteste les gens comme
ça non mais surtout je sais que dans le
coup on a un bon fond mais voilà c'est
qu'une partie de riz log et de rigolade
à chaque fois un et et quand vos copains
quand il s'agit d'être sérieux à il
n'est pas présent alors oui ce m
est ce que je peux demander un service
là c'est tonton cyril qui te le demande
je peux te faire un bisou sur nantes et
ça m'arrange pas je viens de vendée ses
dessous mm
franchement je pense que là il faut que
tu change de costume et tu lui fasse une
vraie déclaration ce que je chante manon
alors un petit peu déçu
si tu veux si tu veux ce que je fais oui
c'est mme lagarde
c'est comme si tu étais tout seul je
vais me cacher sous non je ne te dérange
pas en reste bon je me mets sur le coach
quoi une déclaration dis ce que tu
penses soit sincère
voilà je ne peux pas en fait le diane
bois un ânon liouba nazif armée non
tiens en fait cyril honte à piéger non
sur ma vie il dit en fait ça m'a aidé à
piéger c'est quoi c'est ma copine on
appeler votre on a piégé là on a pigé la
production ça vas et tu m'as a time in
lettre sans lunettes voulu écrire une
lettre mais c'est quoi c'est et renan
luce en fait non en tout cas
un amour tu m'as qu'il est écrit une
lettre
c'est vrai alors si tu veux me pécho je
trouve très sympa de drainer m'a dit que
tu très bon mais là frérot je ne peux
pas que sur tous les dossiers non bâti
jouais bien et glee revient vers tala
travaux très bien côté le monde en fait
j'ai pigé la production je les ai
appelés tout et ça ils ont été sympas
ils sont très gentils
alors dit moi juste pour le voir puisque
en fait un modèle pour moi était une
référence
et bah tu vas pas les mois merci dis-moi
paradigme ça peut être un peu trop bien
de verchères et un nom mais messi à
l'éval celle de shell vas-y cheikh ba ba
c'est moi si je suis venu aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour reconquérir son ex non
c'est plutôt pour te compte hier syrie
au caire compte arrive on va revoir les
concordances mais ça c'est rien l'idée
l'idée est là l'idée là depuis tout
petit j'ai caressé de faire la télé je
vais apprendre ce métier auprès des
meilleurs et pour moi tu es le meilleur
certain amour
on m'a toujours répété que la chance se
provoque il fallait la saisir
toi qui a su saisir ta chance il laisse
moi te prouver que je peux aussi faire
partie de la famille tapez un peu je
sais que tu es un grand coeur toi qui
fais sans cesse de cadeaux le seul
cadeau dont je rêvais c'est du moins de
t'accompagner pendant ses trente cinq
heures tu restes avec moi je veux
réitérer sa victoire pendant 55 heures
je veux tu accompagné pendant soccer
juste tu manges beaucoup n'ont toujours
que juif sur ma vie aujourd'hui je suis
venu de tendre la main en espérant que
tu l'a saisie rabat ps en vous
présentant mes plus mes plus sincères
salutations
mais moi palach - pas là tu sais quoi ce
que j'ai je vais te dire ce que j'ai
aimé le pire c'est que le gars il a
vraiment écrit comme une lettre à la fin
allez on vous présenter mes plus
sincères se tient ces luttes
rendu là chez grosbill
moi j'adore cette drôle est-ce que tu
veux être autour de la table de touche
pas à mon poste demain demain ouais je
fais toutes les missions avec nous
demain je préfère mon agenda
c'est devant que la thématique des
conditions d'émission a laissé des
remerciements
bon alors maintenant je suis un petit
peu ton patron qui souffre ou là là à
portée des nounous value est dans le
slip de matoto de la table mais sur ma
vie est une fête y avoir beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui vont suivre plus de
100 missiles je dors ici moi ça
m'arrange pas mais voilà si tu veux
dormir tu dors voilà on est aujourd'hui
on est place après voilà je kiffe et
tant qu'il est chaud de la télé auprès
de matane amour et ben voilà bah tu m'as
tu seras auprès de moi je vais te dire
que c'est la fin d'une vie saine nos
dames demain
l'émission touche pas à mon poste à
l'aider chéri on va passer à une
nouvelle histoire
tout le monde reste avec notre monde va
bien oui ça va auquel cas vous aviez
bien vu qu'ils n'avaient pas reprendre
avec sa meuf y est on ne fait pas conan
est sûre c'était une femme brune une
jeune femme brune pas parce que vous
êtes visagiste aussi non mais derrière
ce serait beau si je pense que ces
perruques c'était une perruque voix
s'étaient perdus merci mais même sans
perruque on l'aurait pas reconnu ce
qu'on la connaissait pas au départ donc
voila mais bon c'est pas grave alors à
passer une nouvelle histoire
c'est une personne qui va être derrière
un paravent qui veut qui a choisi notre
émission et les 35 heures pour nous
annoncer quelque chose qui lui tient
vraiment à coeur
c'est vraiment très très important pour
lui c'est un jeune homme dont qui est
derrière ce paravent
c'est un paravent chinois portant est ce
que la personne et est installée je
crois que nous sommes en train
d'installer le paravent actuellement
voilà la personne est là est ce que le
jeune homme est là apparemment le jeune
homme fait du bricolage
voilà donc ça y est d'accord apparemment
c'est quelqu'un que c'est vraiment
garder l'anonymat mais l'anonymat diouf
oui on lui a également pratiqué la
bresse qu'on peut le mettre en place
s'il vous plaît j'ai cité remercie et
assez rapidement excusez moi vous faites
de la cuisine
les gars ont la noce au boucau à la 14
merci les domaines nova jette s'ils
pouvaient gagner ton cul je pense qu'on
va pas lui trafic et la voix s'il vous
plaît les chéris parce que je crois
qu'on n'en est pas capable
donc merci jessica voilà de ne pas
trafiqué la voix bonjour alors le jeune
homme est derrière le paravent c'est
bonjour bonjour bonjour alors si on peut
l'entendre quand même s'emboîtent
radicaux 1 est ce qu'on peut l'entendre
s'il vous plaît comment ça va bien
vous m'entendez oui oui je l'entends se
passe on est en direct à ces les 35
heures c'est le banc bête c'est tout ce
qu'on aime merci ya le docteur ya le
docteur qui est là voilà merci non non
on va pas le voir parce qu'il faut pas
qu'on voit jamais alors est ce que vous
êtes équipés merci merci merci benoît
merci c'est quand même le sol docteur il
en arène
[Rires]
les bouquins je peux vous dire s'il
m'arrive quelque chose dégâts mon avis
vous allez perdre un animateur ses 35
heures vont se transformer en journée
hommage
voilà vous êtes vous êtes danseur
oui c'est ça bon là pour l'instant je
dis pas de conneries et j'aimerais vous
demander pourquoi vous êtes sur le
plateau est ce que vous pouvez vous
terre derrière s'il vous plaît merci je
vais le redire en france est-ce que vous
pouvez vous terre derrière sinon je vous
éclater la gueule merci alors voilà nous
l'avait reconnu bien sûr il a joué dans
leur belle aux côtés de lorenzo lamas
il faisait la masse alors donc vous êtes
venu nous voir et là là c'est sérieux il
a vraiment voulu être dans l'émission ce
jeune homme dont je ne peux pas donner
le prénom qui souhaitaient être cachés
pour le moment puisque vous voulez nous
parler de quelque chose et vous vouliez
absolument le dire sur ce plateau
puisque ça vraiment ça vous enlève un
poids c'est ça voilà vous êtes donc
danseurs dans la vie danseur
professionnel tout à fait vous danser ou
dans les discothèques qui est dans des
événements
d'accord nous événement bar mitzvah
divorce
j'imagine ou basse et le divorce de jean
jacques et daniel roux
na na hey hey vous venez nous voir alors
voilà c'est un moment important pour moi
car j'ai décidé de venir sur votre
plateau pour faire mon coming out
donc voilà je je viens sur le plateau
pour avouer à quelqu'un ici que que je
suis gay alors pourquoi pro vouloir le
faire chez nous comme ça parce que c'est
une émission spéciale 35 à pourquoi
vouloir le faire à la télévision pour
aulas ne l'avoir pas dire vos proches
avant alors parce que tout simplement
parce que c'est très compliqué pour moi
parce que jusqu'à maintenant je n'ai
jamais dit je me suis voiler la face
ma famille mes amis mon entourage
n'accepterait pas je pense le face à
face du coup j'ai choisi de vol à la
télé pour pour le dire c'est plus facile
pour moi vraiment vous êtes agent qui
s'y sont pas là et et pour moi c'est
plus facile voilà tout simplement cesser
ce mon avis après c'est parce que je
sois moi je peux très bien laisser le
paravent franchement parce que ça me
gêne un peu aussi si vos proches le
prennent mal et que vous regrettez après
votre demande unis c'est qu'il le sache
maintenant après voilà choisi un peu la
facilité en face l'ordi à travers un
écran pour vous la télévision c'était
c'était la facilité
est-ce que vous avez déjà est en couple
oui et j'ai essayé les filles en fait et
c'est à ce moment là aussi que que j'ai
découvert que c'était pas pour moi ça
s'est mal passé et j'étais en couple
s'était des relations très discrète avec
avec des mecs qui était comme moi qui
cachaient leur box homosexualité et du
coup voilà ça se passait dans la
discrétion alors vous vouliez le révéler
à la télévision ce que vous en avez déjà
un petit peu parlé à vos parents et vos
meilleurs amis ou pas du tout j'ai
jamais dit mot pour mot je suis gay
d'accord ils savent dans quelle dans le
milieu
ça ce que je fais dans la vie donc je
danse
ils savent que voilà je mets des talons
dans les discothèques je fais plein de
choses du coup ils ont peut-être un
doute au fond mais on n'en parle pas en
fait c'est un sujet complètement tabou
et je pense qu'eux aussi se voile la
face et ils veulent pas se l'avouer en
fait au jour d'aujourd'hui en fait vous
voulez voilà vous voulez crever l'abcès
et pouvoir vivre voilà j'ai envie de
voir ce que franchement c'est moi j'en
souffre en fait depuis voilà depuis que
depuis que je l'accepté en tout cas j'en
souffre de cacher tout ça toujours
mentir repas de famille c'est quand tu
auras une cotinine tatatata et non
j'aurais pas de copier mais c'est
compliqué à dire d'accord alors est ce
que je propose c'est on va se retrouver
dans un instant parce que on a fait
venir ici votre meilleur ami qui n'est
pas au courant et elle va elle va
l'apprendre on va avoir sa réaction dans
un instant et puis si vous changez
d'avis si vous décidez vraiment de
rester derrière le paravent
on le comprendra tout à fait et voilà et
on espère en tout cas que ça va bien se
passer
et moi je trouve qu'en tout cas c'est
très courageux ce que vous faites et
voilà je suis fier que vous soyez
mais xavier cornu que par milliers
à ce jeune homme qui à bord a donc ses
nombreux auteurs du coup à sa meilleure
amie
voilà et on aura d'autres histoires
extraordinaires
vous êtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous c'est la
troisième partie en troisième partie un
de tes femmes ont après moi ça va très
vite
je vous dire on avait déjà fait une
heure et nurse coûté une minute d il
nous reste un peu plus de prendre trois
heures après les séries puisque on sera
avec vous pendant 35 heures en direct je
remercie valérie bénaïm peuvent
accompagner coach est édifiant
merci alors les scores sont la preuve
d'ailleurs ça sera de retour demain même
heure 14h 17h avec d'autres témoignages
là on va rester ensemble jusqu'à 17h
ensuite il y aura il en pense quoi
camille et baba avec des défis une
émission spéciale en pense quoi camille
baba ensuite touche pas à mon poste
ensuite c'est pour nous c'est cadeau
ensuite les défis des chroniqueurs on
battra des records tous ensemble face à
des vrais recorman et ensuite toute la
nuit vous pourrez m'appeler après je
vous le dis je dormirai de trois heures
à 5 heures ici sur le plateau pourrait
devoir dormir c'est vrai il ya beaucoup
de chanteurs rêver ça va arriver
vous mettez un chien de fusil oui non
mais la tenue ou frais le fusil
je prendrai ma douche demain matin ce
sera filmé tout ça enfin ce qui est
filmé à bhl a bien entendu fait ce qu'on
n'a pas de gros objectifs
merci oui mais pas pouvoir pour pouvoir
agrandir bien entendu alors pour le
moment nous sommes donc avec d'autres
témoins qui nous ont rejoints merci à
tous d'être là en tout cas ses bras
alors la radio ouï dire qu'ils allaient
voir eux ils ont tous des particularités
folle déjà vous voyez bien mis un garçon
voilà qu'il se fait coiffer qu'un côté
de sa tête
voilà les ads a déjà et ça déjà c'est
pas mal on va revenir vers vous dans un
instant pour le moment nous sommes avec
ce jeune homme qui a pour l'instant
souhaité qu'on ne divulgue pas son
prénom puisque il est venu avec avec une
amie et il voulait donc dévoilé son
homosexualité à ses parents à ses
meilleurs amis ici sur le plateau
puisque pour lui c'était plus facile
il n'arrivait pas à le dire voilà il a
essayé de faire des appels du pire
auprès de sa famille auprès de ses amis
à chaque fois voilà ça ils n'ont ils
n'ont pas compris en fait ce qu'il
voulait qu'il voulait leur dire ce
garçon c'est un danseur il est avec nous
je voulais demander de bien vouloir
venir de derrière le paravent merci à
lui d'être avec nous c'est tranquille
alors ok nous a donné la terre en tout
cas si toi sur canapé toi tu as le
brocade ap oui voilà ces plaisirs va pas
mal
eh bien je m'assure près de toi on va
être bientôt on va être bien tous les
deux voilà alors anthony est venu sur
notre plateau donc pour avouer son
homosexualité tête avec quelqu'un ce
moment ou pas du tout houla non non pour
l'instant tu étais libre n'ont pas vu
surtout tu es très beau gosse par six
acheteurs guide nature et la coiffure
dont je rêve à un bref autant je permets
de te dit tu as la coiffure dont je rêve
que le piercing dont je rêve tu as le
jeans dont je ne rêve pas mais la mer
mais tu as tout merci en tout cas d'être
avec nous retenait alors tu es venu
enfin enfin il est venu il ya ta
meilleure amie cayla qui s'appelle
céline et céline elle n'est pas du tout
au courant qu'elles venaient pour ça je
crois un original croyez qu'elle venait
complètement pour tourcoing cannes et
pourquoi on fait dans l'émission
incroyable c'était par rapport au
casting que j'ai pu faire secret story
est tous à la salle et bristol je sais
que toi tu avais fait des choses ou au
tu disais que tu voulais être célèbre
c'est ça c'était ton rêve c'était d'être
célèbre en fait je voulais faire mon
coming out il ya longtemps déjà et
j'avais été approché par la production
de secret story et j'ai voyagé pas été
pris ok gardez maman j'ai passé les deux
premières étapes ils m'ont fait venir à
paris tout ça et puis voilà ça s'est pas
fait et du coup quand j'ai vu l'appel à
témoins ne saisit pas pourquoi pas le
faire à avec vous merci merci d'être
avec nous tout cas moi je suis très
heureux de t'avoir avec nous
pareillement j'espère que tu vas rester
avec nous pendant tout le reste et les
35 heures on va commerce à lille
parce que c'est ta meilleure amie et
c'est lille on a dit on n'a jamais eu sa
réaction
céline céline aller où mais elle est où
céline a balayé installe toi reste à toi
céline alors céline donc anthony est ton
meilleur ami
on parle parle bien dans le micro merci
merci pas mal c'est le soldat qui amène
un fauteuil qui le jette mon frère ilana
pottas il a fait comme ça d'habitude
dans les émissions sans déconner chez
arthur site où il pose le fauteuil
arthur historiquement bas
[Musique]
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça que tu me
fais avec moi après tout ce que j'ai
fait pour toi català c'est moi qui vais
acheter sa chemise de bûcheron comme ça
alors céline déjà déjà merci d'être là
si op il peut s'occuper des chaises et
arrêter de discuter derrière le paravent
merci alors on parle bien dans le micro
céline alors c'est ton meilleur ami si
anthony oui c'est mon meilleur ami je
reconnais être venus ensemble oui alors
est ce que est ce que tu tu savais pas
du tout pour que vous veniez firent
alors si on m'avait parlé que ce serait
un thème sur leurs rêves de célébrité
sécrète sabri toutes ces choses là mais
pas du tout pour cette révélation tu
t'en douter ou pas du tout oui
maintenant qu'on me le dit oui je peux
demande je pouvais m'en douter mais tu
avais peur de sa réaction toni ou pas du
tout non c'est pour ça que j'ai fait
venir justement ces lignes parce que je
savais qu'elle allait je savais qu'elle
allait l'accepter directement enfin
c'est tout ce que je fais elle me voit
danser en boîte des fois donc c'est un
petit peu la logique des choses aussi un
d'accord et et céline même même tu
penses continue c'est bien ce qui est ce
qui la fait devenir le dire à la
télévision même pour sa famille pour ses
parents tout ça qui compte pour lui
c'est un poids qui s'en va ou pas du
tout oui je pense parce que ça faisait
enfin ça faisait longtemps que je
voulais le dire je pense mais j'ai
vraiment je suis fier de lui
merci beaucoup j'ai voulu j'ai voulu
aussi le faire va aussi parce que tout
le monde dit voilà qu'on est bientôt en
2017 que c'est plus tabou tout ça mais
il ya beaucoup de jeunes comme moi qui
le cachent encore et voilà j'ai aussi
envie de donner l'exemple et voilà et ça
m'enlève un poids également et et voilà
et il ya une association qui fait un
travail formidable s'appelle le refuge
aussi voilà avec qui s'occupe de deux
garçons et deux filles voilà qui n'osent
pas avouer leur homosexualité ou bien
qu'ils sont rejetés par leurs parents à
la suite de deux
voilà de tenir la suite voilà donc et
après ils font savoir à leurs parents
qu'ils sont homosexuels ils sont rejetés
par leur famille et il s'occupe d'eux
extrêmement bien donc ça c'est une
association vraiment con qu'on soutient
également avec toutes les équipes voilà
de ces 8es de et de touche pas à mon
poste
alors alors anthony ce que tu te sens
mieux ça va mieux là donc
et quand tu veux tu habites chez tes
parents pas oui j'avais deux schémas un
an quand tu vas voir ta maman ce soir
qu'elle est sûre et lui dire c'est cette
façon à la page non mais non mais voilà
enfin ce tollé que je vous dise moi donc
tu savais mais un lapin géant de chez
vous voilà bah très bien alors
franchement vous n'étiez on a déjà
wissem qui va passer les 35 heures avec
nous tu sais que je suis là pendant un
an mais ça va bien se passer je pense je
sais par écouter on verra vas tu nous
tiendrons au courant pas avec plaisir si
tu veux nous dire demain parce que
demandent encore là si tu veux nous dire
comment ça s'est passé avec ta maman
basse avec plaisir on espère que ça se
passera bien et si tu veux que j'arrive
moi même parler à ta maman
binger j'irai voilà je suis mobile un g1
un gros merci merci ma chaîne merci
antho merci
valérie valeriquais ce que l'on pensait
selon penser que c'est bien de le faire
à la télévision comme ça ou bien c'est
vraiment compliqué mais après je
comprends effectivement je fais démarche
parce que parfois de de dire à la
personne en face on veut pas la blesser
ou on veut pas avoir la discussion
réellement donc c'est une façon
d'annoncer pour que la personne puisse
encaisser éventuellement si c'est
difficile pour elle a encaissé et
ensuite ça permet d'amorcer une
discussion un peu plus tard quand les
choses sur un tout petit peu apaisées
donc je pense que du coup il y aura un
petit peu de recul quelques heures où ce
sera sa part au descendre en pression et
après on paie 10 à l'oublier mais
calmement il est absolument charmant
qu'est ce que vous en pensez nos
psychologues parce qu'avec les familles
comme ça derrière comment est ce que
c'est c'est pas trop brut comme ça à la
télévision de la vérité tout à l'heure
ils disaient que il avait choisi la
facilité
moi j'ai une forme d'admiration pour
vous finalement parce que au contraire
c'est la manière peut-être la plus dure
cela demande malheureusement encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de courage et de
force pour se préparer éventuellement à
cet éventuel rejet derrière et les qu'en
dira t'on et est au contraire je trouve
qu'il est très courageux et peut-être
que ça va effectivement poussé d'autres
jeunes et moins jeunes parce qu'il ya
très très longtemps à peut-être faire ce
qu'on appelle un coming-out d'accord va
très bien mme anthony en tout cas on est
tous très heureux de l'avoir
la réaction de sa maman alors les cherry
à côté de valérie ils vont venir tous
les deux puisque faille et son relooking
est terminée alors j'aimerais qu'on
montre xavier vis-à-vis est ce qu on n
en a que xavier il ya quelques instants
parce que xavier était avec nous sur le
plateau voilà et xavier regarder il est
parti comme ça et xavier pour l'instant
il n'a jamais connu l'amour
il est sympathique il est il y va quand
même hein il est gratuit draghi doit
quand même des filles sur internet
ils envoient des sms tout ça mais pour
l'instant voilà il n'a pas conclu et
william carnimolla la relooker tout de
suite en j'ai hâte de voir ça xavier
relooké par william c'est parti on y va
bien nous écouter
[Applaudissements]
on a fait ce qu'on a trouvé la pâte pas
trop quand même alors williams la
chaleur va je ne valide pas tout à mes
lunettes sont chez nous ils les gardent
l'espoir mais il était bien une et que
j'aime bien je trouve que tous vont bien
mon chéri on dirait rika zaraï peut voir
moi j'adore tout le reste franchement je
trouve ça chiant car une verte mais bon
c'est un garçon assez bien corps est
vrai parce que c'est vrai que c'est
costaud et ouais alors et qu'est ce qui
se passe en fait alors voilà c'est que
ce qui suit le fait que je suis battu la
chaux dit ça on a déjà ses pantalons
puisqu'ils portaient des choses l'argent
ça devait le réaliser ces silhouettes
dont on a trouvé les choses de plus
libre il a mal aux pieds mais des
chaussures c'est marie thomas du chausse
du 42 ans et sa taille on n'a pas
l'habitude à 28 chose qui garde quand
même un énorme et la chemise c'est super
mais on est fait de bois la branche man
est un petit peu désolé et puis un peu
aviez jeu les chaussures et je charrie
pas je tiendrai là c'est un super gars
normalement tu dois trouver une mop là
je te le dis et sur pratique on rigole
et à prix principal c'est pas les
fringues c'est quoi le principal c'est
quoi la con sur la confiance
l'attitude est là mais il faut que tu te
sentes en confiance je te jure xavier
que les hyper sympathique je te le dis
lapin de meuf qui meurent est avec toi
d'accord on se fait un gros bisou
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
il ya des phrases et non il me dit y'a
pas moyen de carotène iphone des fois
oui mais avec un iphone on lui offre un
smartphone en
[Applaudissements]
merci merci que jamais la barre est avec
nous merci de la dore et mais j'ai à
vous dire je comprends pas pour les
trouver il est hyper sympathique
c'est un ouf y'a pas moyen de carotte un
iphone je crois qu'il est trop casse
avec les meufs c'est ça je pense qu on a
trouvé le dos ça on a trouvé le dos
allez on va accueillir nos nouveaux
invités alors il ya elle est restée avec
me gérer notre miss cougar merci d'être
là en tout cas à côté de vous il y à
michel michel il a 82 ventura un mot
michel 89 ans retraité de quoi de
l'assurance assurance laquelle la sfac
c'est la seule qui relie gypse très
spécialisés c'est l'assurance il se
passe des choses est comme un cerf gamme
d'accor et et vous avez une
particularité c'est vrai parce que vous
avez 89 ans à votre avis qui a essayé de
trouver williams baleri claude et et
vous keita que keith qu'est-ce qui l'a
40 est pour l'a dit nous à votre avis
quelle est sa particularité vous pouvez
lui poser des questions
c'est une particularité physique que
vous avez valérie pascale michel de
l'échelle ne pensais pas que ça pouvait
pour avoir on vous doit pied ou est ce
que je vois où était le onzième
[Rires]
les relais 180 d'abord parce que c'est
une particularité pratiques ou utile si
vous n'avez pas compris la question
comme vous comme chez des inconnus vous
répéter la question c'est ça est ce que
vous vous servez de votre particularité
pour faire quelque chose est ce que ces
pratiques oui voilà et est ce que vous
l'avez toujours une vous l'avez
développés où elle est arrivée à un
moment donné un moment donné oui et non
normalement on a un voyant normalement
le voyant pas bien claude voulait qu'on
revienne aux honneurs ressembler défis
en ce qui vous concerne les ya quelque
chose avec un apport sportif charest il
écrit tous très fort ce mec un émetteur
on rigole mais claude pour vous dire que
c'est un taux lire comment tu as fait
pour tomber ça parce que je ressemble à
ce que je dois bouger je vois très actif
et anna fois on le voit le canada comme
des montagnes et c'est pour ça je vous
dirais qu'il ya quelquefois escalader
les montagnes
oui je les fais un moment bref un moment
c'est vrai oui oui oui oui oui là
jusqu'à la dd montagne révélé il n'était
pas du tout mais alors à la mjc dans le
sport et badauds qui vous êtes
marathonien non il a enfin ils
pratiquent un sport et il est un
champion à 89 c'est un sport en rapport
avec vous oui abonde ma ping ping pong
c'est un champion ou ping pong c'est un
pongiste
il a 80
alors et et vous avez commencé à 46 ans
quel est votre plus grand titre vous
avez été vous avez été champion de quoi
alors j'ai été choqué en 2000 il ya
quatre ans est comme j'étais médaille
d'argent en double ah oui et cette année
un lit quand j'étais médaille d'argent
en simple nom deux fois le championnat
ou décliner plus de alors l'année
dernière il ya quatre ans c'était 85 ans
et plus ouais et cette année ses 90 ans
et plus non parce que vous avez 90 sa
série j'aurais quatre-vingt dix ans le
11 novembre
franchement alors moi ce que j'attends
de cet âge là pour avoir des titres ping
pong c'est donc j'espère que ça
m'arrivera également alors moment ce que
je propose c'est qu'on fasse quand même
un petit mano tous les deux en trois
points effet on a une table du pain ou
alors venez une table de ping pong mais
damien on gagne quelque chose
alors si nous met une tannée 6 me met
une tannée et ben on verra est-ce que
vous avez votre raquette
non j'ai oublié ma raquette mais là où
ça a quand même on lui dit tu viens pour
faire un ping pong le gars oublie ça
avec moi parce que vous allez voir 89
ans michel lemay nettement on a installé
la table juste derrière 5 anthony
antonio qui l'attend le médecin
comme on l'entendait inquiète pas mon
chéri ça va le médecin garder le médecin
est là pour les 35 heures jamais en
panne entre 5 heures il ya 2000 euros
pour l'association ce que ça fait deux
heures qu'on est à l'antenne de
l'émission bonjour
[Applaudissements]
regardez notre cycliste qui va pédaler
pendant 35 heures ça fait déjà deux
heures ça va marcher mais tout va bien
tu es beau tu es magnifique
allez on y va alors mon chéri le qui
[ __ ] toujours riche l on y va alors là
et je n'ai jamais joué contre h au pire
on l'a c'est énorme
ah pardon
alors on y va on y vend haut niveau en
trois points en trois points gagnants
ces partis eux
alors on l'a on la refait on l'annonçait
tu peux vite les laroquais arrivait pas
a vécu à la raquette fait attention à
trois points c'est parti
à 0 % de ses parts tout qu'est ce que je
dis
[Musique]
appart ou michel à poitiers à rien alors
on y va en trois points
je suis chaud là michel fut chaud dois
je faire attention c'est partout
d'accord je ne fais pas
de partout balle de match balle de match
michel ont fait à paris tous les deux
sur cette balle de match balle de match
alors attention si je gagne je feins
smac à valérie benaïm si tu gagnes tu ce
matin valérie bénaïm tu fais un petit
bisou à valérie bénaïm d'accord avec
plaisir l'annoncé je gâte
si je gagne tu fais un bisou à valérie
benaïm si tu gagnes
je fais un bisou à valérie vidal a battu
jeannie autorise canon alors obligé de
dire si tu gagnes
oui je fais un bisou à claude alexis oui
d'accord et si je gagne tu fais un gros
bisou à valérie benaïm sur la bouche
rien sur la bouche on est comme ça
pourrait voir ouais ouais bien sûr c'est
parti
se gagne et c'est gagné benhaim michel
mais cette fois carrément du surinam la
médiathèque mois avec michel pas
tensions avec moi
oui
[Applaudissements]
m
cla
[Applaudissements]
la semaine
les papilles c'est lui qui je le sais
mais cher est ce que ça vous fait
plaisir déjà je fasse un bide vous avez
envie de relever un bisou bien sûr
j'avais la pression pas trop aller aller
on tente duvet d'oie les jeunes et chez
eux ça va
[Applaudissements]
à
je sais pas si ça me regarde ça monsieur
sale temps pour nous marier et du
message votre mission vous êtes mariés
depuis 65 ans non c'est bon quand vous
pouvez voir chez vous notre cougar a
beaucoup rajeuni
il ya des témoins qui succède voilà
c'est tout ce qu'on apprenne comment tu
t'appelles ma chérie mais vannes à ça va
merci d'être là on cherchait pourtant à
quel âge j'ai 11 ans d'accord on faisant
92 ans vous regardez des mariés ont même
déjà allez on va passer on va passer à
hamel bonjour hamel ça bien alors hamel
vous êtes magnifique alors franchement
quelle boutique vous avez 18 ans ouais
c'est ça
cette étudiante en quoi ans dans le
commerce commerce quoi je fais un dut
tech de co techniques de
commercialisation sco n'est jamais
parfait failli le faire donc et non mais
c'est vrai
dut tout ça à l'image limoges devrait
alors se lève il me joue embrasse
limoges magnifique ville très bon club
de basket c'est important vous aviez une
histoire extraordinaire en fait vous
êtes là pour votre maman oui voilà
cette maman alors racontez nous tout en
fait votre maman est venue avec vous
aujourd'hui
voilà c'est pas pourquoi elle est là si
elle sait pourquoi enfin elle se doute
pas de la vérité quoi elle croit qu'elle
est là pour quoi elle croit qu'elle est
la pauvre donc un reportage quand une
petite interview pour moins de 30
minutes
chez i télé pour sur la vie étudiante
quoi pour la coi sur la plan en rapport
avec la vie étudiante d'accord est en
fait quelle est la particularité de
votre maman la particularité maman c'est
qu'elle est fan de vous armer à en
mourir que vraiment passer l'oral à
francis cabrel coach j'aurai les ans
francis cabrel quoi révolter regret dit
non c'est vrai que méritée hyper plaisir
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que on va
les surprendre sa maman dans un instant
on ne sait pas que je valais d'avoir et
je ferai un gros bisou à votre maman
elle vraiment contente de revoir ou au
moins d'un jour mais ça se laisse la
surprise mais je pense que les salles va
nous raconter comment ça se manifeste
chez un ami dans un instant magique vous
allez nous dire principe paraît vraiment
elle est très contente de me voir à la
télé tous envie oui ça me fait
extrêmement replay et le replay je lui
fais un gros bisou on va la retrouver
dans un instant ne sais pas pourquoi il
a ce sera la surprise à nous lire parce
qu'elle fait à la maison etc et on aura
d'autres témoignages
on aura donc une personne pour l avez
compris bien sûr je ne me coiffe que
d'un côté ce sera dans un instant on a
bien sûr donc soir aux côtes
merci d'être avec nous se fait vite nous
sommes dans les 35 heures de direct ça
démarre par cette émission ne touche pas
à mon après avec plein de témoignages
aura la même émission demain pas avec
les mêmes témoins pas faire tous les
jours les mêmes témoins donc forcément
avec d'autres personnes qui seront avec
nous demain et bien sûr dans un instant
doha ils en pensent quoi camille dès 17h
camille et baba donc je serai aux côtés
de camille pour une émission spéciale je
vous le dis avec plein de défis derrière
touche pas à mon poste
derrière c'est pour nous c'est cadeau
une histoire est de fous et ses ponts de
cé cadeaux derrière des défis est
derrière toute la nuit avec vous les
chéris ça fait exactement
2h20 un coup seulement grecque donc il
ya donc bien mieux
pour l'association c'est que du bonheur
puisque à chaque heure place et on donne
1000 euros à cette association qui
s'occupe des enfants qui fait un travail
exceptionnel voilà mes chéris alors nous
sommes pour l'instant avec amel on vient
de faire la connaissance de michel qui
était champion de ping pong 89 ans
médaille d'argent
et ouais donc magnifique on à la petite
levana qui est venu nous rejoindre on
saura pourquoi dans un instant on a le
fils de jean louis david qui est là vous
pouvez le voir voilà qui nous dira mais
quelle est sa passion et et vous verrez
et on a un homme que j'ai rencontrés
dans les loges avec qui on s'est très
bien entendu vous verrez ce qui fait
déjà ce que vous avez une petite idée ou
pas il est beau ouais il est bon un
militaire un peu en dire un militaire
alors vous verrez ombre on saura ça tout
à l'heure pour le moment nous sommes
avec amel et hamel alors vous avez dit
votre maman elle est là les dans les
locaux non elle ne sais pas du tout
pourquoi elle venait qu'elle venait pour
une interview pour i télé est en fait
votre maman aussi bizarre que cela
puisse paraître est fan demande alors
quel âge elle a quarante six 46 ans et
donc ça n aurait bourgade tous les soirs
dont tous les soirs les matins dès
qu'elle a loupé la veille quand elle
travaille l'été en l'air oui c'est une
catastrophe non mérite donc du coup ils
essaient de se refaire tout à fait des
fois je la surprend elle est carrément
sur google images pour te regarder
les panneaux mais c'est pas du fanatisme
ne laissait pas te ressembler un jour
inquiétant à la raison oui mais oui oui
je ne lui conseille pas mais et qu'elle
te connaît et elle est toujours avec mon
papa ou pas non du tout ah d'accord
je vous dis qu'est ce qu'il aurait dit
tout ça oui c'est pas pareil thèmes
comme un frère mais j'espère voilà
comment foucault marois comme une star
de cinéma
non mais non mais je sais alors on a on
à tabac vont donc aïcha elle est
conseillère en clientèle où ça à tulle à
tulle d'accord c'est en corrèze proche
des brèches comme je connais un peu
folle
c'est encore le président à ce que je
sache la soul est elle elle fait quoi
conseiller en clientèle ou sa demande en
quoi dans la téléphonie mobile
ah ouais d'accord alors regarde là elle
et on dirait qu'elle a tendu et serré le
sénateur ouais il est en salle d'attenté
ne sais pas pourquoi elle est là donc ce
que je vais faire c'est que je vais m je
vais mettre cette veste chez maître
cette veste je vais mettre ce casque et
je vais arriver aux livreurs ou de
livrer des fleurs pour voir après sa
réaction quand elle va boire et là c'est
la cas de mme huff le voit effet à
quelle horreur alors je vais que je vais
gagner
regardez voilà vous dire si je suis je
passe bien par cette voie vous allez
voir je mets ça je vais d'abord quand
même il est très sérieux ça va très bien
vraiment me reconnais là
[Rires]
avant d'y aller un petit point médical
avec le docteur ça va comme en bas vous
savoir bah oui c'est normal
un bonne nouvelle les dentistes sont
arrivées ce que pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent j'ai perdu une dent tout à
l'heure j'ai la dent allé dans la poche
merci pour vous
[Musique]
ça va dit ça pour tous les trois mois
sachez qu'avec moi avec moi mais avec
moi ma chérie tu es un tiens tiens
mais comment ça va mon bébé s'avachir y
voit rien toi
et ouais mais je suis trop content de te
voir on est on à avoir on est avec kamel
en fait honte à piéger
c'est pour ça il ya patrick étudiants
mais non il n'y a aucun truc et il a
juste un mec qui fait du vélo salut ça
fait 2 120 qui pédalent lui le pauvre
quand même bien mais je suis trop
content tout mais qui est magnifique
elle me dit je suis pas arrangés pour
passer à la télé les magnifiques
regarder aïcha qui est avec nous cet
après midi ça s'est donc hissé d'entrée
[Musique]
amaga
[Applaudissements]
jamais
astral est bon et aïcha je suis trop
content de te voir
mais vraiment moi aussi alors sans
fatigue mais il paraît que tu me
regardes tous les soirs je peux parler
dans le vide qu'est ce qui te ferait
plaisir qu'est ce que je peux faire pour
toi enlevez déjà que tu fais tous les
soirs quoi c'est vrai tu venir me voir
un jour je t'invite à l'émission pas où
tu en as rien à fond avec nous ce soir
pour touche pas à mon poste et ou pas
c'est vrai oui j'aurais bien ouais ça
ferait plaisir à m je reste avec nous
reste donc vous restez avec mort vous
faites touche pas à mon poste avec moi
vous aimez d'après vous venez assez pour
nous c'est cadeau oui vous dormez
ouzouer sais pas bah c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau on vous prend une petite
chambre resta là ce soir
bon
[Musique]
bon alors messieurs mois voilà moi je
suis c'est tout mais petite fermette
qu'est ce que tu aimes dans l'émission
c'est qui ton chroniqueurs préférés
mais d'abord valérie valérie elle est
sympa c'est le coup de cherves elle est
sympa un brushing c'est ça même moi vous
m'avez pas il est enfin arrêté non et
vous vous c'est qui votre chroniqueur
préféré après vous après toi je te
tutoie puisque tous les soirs à la
maison quand même un oui je connais ce
soit le bon jean michel maire
jean-michel verts qui pourra lui faire
un beau bijou aïcha d'accord et donc tu
restes avec nous ça y est ou amel et
aïcha vous reste avec nous c'est bon
c'est dans la boîte
on ressent un tu veux que je me change
c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que je
t'aime merci ma chérie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]